what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and marvel studios finally decided to
bless us with their final eternals
trailer before the movie's debut this
november a trailer featuring everyone's
favorite big ass cosmic nerds of mystery
the celestials finally making their
first appearance in the mcu since essen
the searchers brief cameo in guardians
of the galaxy vol 1. but just who are
the celestials anyway and how might the
celestials factor into our upcoming
marvel titles well let's talk about it
my beautiful nerd babies because if you
thought you had weird uncles just you
know wait till you meet peter quills
because he's got some really
really weird uncles before we talk about
peter's uncle let's talk about peter's
grandpa no not the white one i'm talking
about the father of all the celestials
the first firmament the manifestation of
the first ever marvel universe before
the multiverse even existed the first
firmament was the one and only universe
in existence but that being the case the
first firmament got really lonely and
decided to create life and so they did
along with the celestial race to create
and manage all of that new life however
there are two types of celestial beings
the dark celestials who kissed the first
firmament's ass and aspired to please
him were called the aspirants and the
more rebellious multicolored ones that
we know as the celestials the ass
kissing aspirin sought the first for
women's approval every time they created
life and since daddy firmament was
boring and wanted life to stay the same
and never change or die that's the type
of life that they primarily made however
the multicolored celestials wanted life
and the universe to grow and evolve and
eventually die because change is what
makes life cool so they rebelled against
the first firmament kicking off the
celestial war between the ass kissers
and the rainbow rebels a war that ended
with the celestials detonating a weapon
that blew chunks out of the first
firmament and those chunks became
separate universes of their own and then
all of those chunks collectively
together became known as the first ever
multiverse by the name of the second
cosmos so after the first firmament and
his loyal aspirants ran away after the
celestial war to plot their revenge the
celestials went on to continue their
evolutionary experiments with and within
the second cosmos and then when that
multiverse died after billions of years
the third cosmos and then so on and so
forth until we get to the current and
most well-known cosmos of all eternity
the seventh cosmos now if we could
condense the main drive behind the
celestial race into one word that word
would be
life like life is the name of the game
it is their very nature to seek out and
deal and manage with life and we can
even see that within the mcu with the
rogue celestial ego of the living planet
i told you how all those years ago i had
an unceasing impulse to
find life even though ego lived a life
separate and alone from his celestial
brothers he literally did not know of
them at all the drive towards life was
within him nonetheless albeit corrupted
by his own messed up interpretation of
what that innate drive meant but the
celestial's main function as a group is
to seek out life in its early caveman
stages conduct genetic experiments on
that life that allow it to evolve leave
and then wait a couple millennia to see
how those races evolve like they've done
this to the humans the skrulls the cree
the little green men from toy story the
zandarians basically all things sentient
after the big bang have evolved because
of celestial intervention in their
distant past and the results of their
experiments left those species with
three types of life the genetically
perfect eternals the genetically messed
up deviants and the regular basic
species like humanity but within that
base species the genetic potential to
become more the celestials made sure to
put a latent x gene in there that would
give rise to mutants on that planet when
the time was right and this is where our
favorite mutants from the x-men comics
and cyclops come from which means that
chloe zhao's upcoming eternals film will
more than likely be the mcu movie that
will finally usher in mutants to the mcu
through the mass activation of this
latent mutant gene that the celestials
left behind and let's not forget that
the celestials are a crucial part in the
creation of the omega level mutant
apocalypse because apocalypse gets his
powers directly from s in the searcher
but a huge thank you to skillshare for
sponsoring this video skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes for curious
creative folks and skillshare lets you
explore new skills deepen existing
passions and get lost in creativity
skillshare offers classes designed for
real life learn and grow with short
classes that fit any schedule and each
class is a combination of video lessons
and a class project and it's curated
specifically for learning meaning that
there are no ads and there are always
launching new premium classes so you can
stay focused and follow wherever your
creativity takes you they have classes
and topics new rockstars fans will enjoy
like animation film music and
freelancing one other classes that looks
pretty cool is productivity or creatives
build a system that brings out your best
buy mr thomas frank he's a prolific
musician and content creator and his
classes go over stuff like how to set up
your physical and digital space to work
for you not against you i definitely
need that because my room is a disaster
zone hey but good news gang the first 1
000 of our subscribers to click the link
in the description will get a one month
free trial of skillshare so that you can
start exploring your creativity today so
do it get on it because skillshare is
pretty dang cool gotta say and thank you
so much again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video you guys are
amazing but fun fact celestial genetic
intervention is also why superheroes
even exist on our planet not sure if you
knew this but usually high levels of
radiation will kill you and in the
marvel universe it usually does as well
but sometimes sometimes like in the case
of captain america the hulk and she-hulk
spider-man captain marvel spectrum miss
marvel and of course the fantastic four
it doesn't and it allows them to mutate
in their own special way they're not
mutants mutates different from mutants
but yeah whenever a celestial visits a
planet that visit is usually called a
host but don't let that fool you because
it's not very hospitable not at all
they're quite actually so
earth's first celestial host is when the
celestials first came to earth and
experimented on the oogaboogas and left
the eternals in charge of overseeing
their evolution that's the scientific
name for early man and the second
celestial host is when they came back
thousands of years after to check on how
we were all doing however during that
second celestial host the dumbass
deviants were in charge of the earth and
decided to piss off the celestial so bad
enough to trigger a worldwide apocalypse
known as the great cataclysm causing the
landscape and service of the earth to
change completely in the ancient city of
atlantis to fall into the ocean around
like 18 000 bce and this is 100
how we will be getting neymar into the
mcu mr steel yo invisible girl himself
because the celestials play a key role
in the formation of namor's sub-aquatic
domain of atlantis which gives me hope
that his potential introduction in
eternals could lead us to a potential
wakanda atlantis war being introduced in
wakanda forever and good god was that
war messy like neymar t'challa go at it
so many people die it's great great
family fun for everybody now let's talk
about the third and fourth host of the
celestials because this is where thor
love and thunder and maybe projects like
moon knight and wakanda forever could
tie in because the third time the
celestials came to visit 1 000 years
before the modern times odin assembled
all the head gods of earth like your
zeus's and your vishnu's and your kong
shoes and your basts the whole pantheon
to form the council of godheads and
together the pantheon tried to confront
the celestials but immediately
collectively shipped their pantheon
pants when they found out that the
u-change clan ain't nothing to with
in the pantheon then swore to never
interfere with humanity and the
celestial's plans for the next 1 000
years because a thousand years after
that is when the celestials would come
back to finally judge whether or not the
planet was up to their standards and if
humanity isn't
well you know
so to prepare for this fourth and
potentially apocalyptic celestial host
odin and the rest of the gods decided to
create the destroyer armor in hopes of
being able to defend humanity from a
celestial apocalypse the very same
destroyer armor from thor one so with
thor love and thunder confirmed to
feature russell crowe zeus and christian
bale's gore the god butcher i think it's
safe to assume that the marvel pantheon
of gods including gods like black
panther's bast and moon knight's conscie
could be assembling in the mcu to
confront a new flow in christian bale's
gore and possibly a coming host of the
celestials to mcu earth because you know
those mothers are coming back because we
are nothing but their guinea pigs i mean
if a fourth host isn't covered in the
eternals movie anyway but that is the
celestials in a super condensed nutshell
how do you guys think the celestials
will factor into the mcu moving forward
do you think the mcu celestial day of
judgment is upon us or will that big
celestial day of judgement be the next
big mcu threat do that speculating thing
below speculation nation but anyways
thank you so much for watching this
video you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird but most
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are and when you do please
hit that notification bell on youtube so
you can get notifications whenever we
upload some dope and please follow
us on twitter because our twitter
presence is phenomenal in our twitter
guy tyler it's kind of the man i don't
know if you heard tyler he's kind of
doing his thing he's uh he's killing it
that is it for me catch you guys later
goodbye
[Music]
you